welcome back to this man sitting to my
right f is for family the third season
of the animated hilarious Netflix series
is live for streaming right now on
Netflix he is none other than Bill burr
how are you bill
I'm doing good how are you sir I'm doing
fine what's going on in your life
what are you doing this nothing I'm off
the road for the year the road yeah I
love it just got back from New York and
I've been hanging out with the wife and
kids
nice on the tree I'm all about it I said
what's that process like lights on the
tree in the burn well we waited til our
daughter went to sleep she had a little
bit of a cough so it took a little while
your daughter gonna be too okay so she's
not part of the process she's not
getting on a ladder or anything like no
no so you know had a little eggnog no
booze in it trying to be a good boy and
I still almost fell into the tree the
usual part when you get up high how tall
is this tree I thought we got a big one
um you know my wife wanted you know now
that we have the kid she really wants to
like do it up so she's been trying to
like go out and buy all this stuff you
know reindeers and all of this crap and
I was trying to get her to rent it cuz I
was just like well what are you gonna do
what are you gonna do the other 48 weeks
of the put it in a box and then you pop
it out next year no no cuz then it just
keeps coming and she's like an artist so
she says every year it's a different
theme and so it's just gonna be like
snowmen next year and it's just gonna
pile up and it's gonna end up in the
garage and the garage is mine she gets
the house I get the garage and I'm not
gonna have that garage or I got a
step-over
tooth fairies and Easter bunnies and all
of this crap them that's not happening
what is in your house that's yours but
you brought to the marriage you brought
to the equation that is still in the out
of the garage actually in the bill burn
the house household that is yours going
through all the rooms there's yeah
there's nothing I have my clothes that's
it not a chair that's what the funny
figures all these women out there
bitching that they don't have any power
it's ridiculous dude I did Madison
Square Garden I got home within 36 hours
I'm walking on eggshells in my own house
sorry I it's not how he meant it
you know it's just like what the problem
is in my house I have one chair one
chair that I brought to the marriage
relationship was like
fifteen 20 years ago now that's it yeah
the rest of it it's like that it's like
the scene from poltergeist where the
entity just sucks all the belongings
into it it's gone poof goes away and
then they like something you don't like
it and it can't just be I go you don't
like it let's move on to something else
it just becomes like why why don't you
like I like it like I buy it no I want
you to like it it's just like this is
this is why I'm gonna die before you
because you're putting me through this
so my thing is the garage like you can
eat off the floor okay I got you know
once one side I have an old truck an old
Ford truck I'm a Ford guy and then the
other side I have soundproof I play
drums so now whenever I get new I start
to you know arguing with my wife right I
go for a walk I just gonna go for a walk
I go out I played a Pantera for like 25
minutes and I don't care anymore and
your new man yeah I come on the garage
that's it I'm going to the garage yeah
I'm going for a walk and how big is this
garage - it's two cars three two car
that's it it's modest yeah it's modest
but you got the drum set in there and so
I got my guy can little pull-up bar a
little place to do a little workout and
then that's it that's it just just
there's nothing I got a little I got a
little humidor out there for my cigars
that's it then it's a ten you could fit
a car after all two-car garage you just
soundproof one side you parked the car
on the other side and then that's it
what's the theme for the Christmas tree
this year but uh I don't know she
decides all of that okay like goes like
because we were trying to think like she
goes you want to go blue lights this
year then we looked it up going his way
said stepping on Hanukkah and then
people say sometimes you put blue lights
on that means somebody just died what do
you mean by stepping on Hanukkah take
away from the thing you know like well
you're gesturing towards the rich eyes
and showmen or oh that's your colors you
know I don't wanna be like hey man I
don't like apropriate my holiday colors
you know you're not trying to sneak a
Tom Brady ornament on the tree or
anything like that could you sneak it
like a Bella check ornament on the tree
I don't need no need to they win they
get rings and all of that no I don't
need to like my wife was against
dressing my daughter in any sort of
sports gear or anything like that what
do you mean she just didn't want to do
it cuz she's going you're talking about
her just in general so eyes not like I
Patriot onesie in your house right
what's there is I ignored all of that I
just dressed her up and now she thinks
it's cute no she even that she is like
she's at Michigan Wolverine stuff she's
got yeah yeah yeah my one of my family
members went there so right yeah we are
mission killer that was a tough one few
weeks ago BRR oh the worst I mean it
just in terms of this is the year was
supposed to happen it should have
happened it had to happen and now Urban
Meyer's leaving so even if you beat him
next year it's like he wanted to beat
the guy that was beating you know is
that your view of urban leaving right
now you think you wanted him to stay
right yeah that was like back in the day
like you know if you know the few times
Derek Jeter got hurt is a Red Sox fan if
you beat the Yankees that day it's like
we didn't beat the Yankees you know
Jeter's not there you know so you want
to beat him with their best so yeah yeah
I mean I hit everybody was over no I got
I had her head or head her you know
Jersey on would sure what Jersey she
have on Oh
number one was what did I get her I got
her a Wolverines I can't remember cuz I
bought my nephew the Tom Brady one I
don't know it was a sea of blue mace my
god and so again we would like like that
for about three minutes and then we all
just like you know that's good yeah it
was not only yeah a bad loss it was also
just it just everything that they could
have done wrong like that one they
should have let go in the end zone you
catch it and go out of bounds on the
whole apart it was a nightmare
yeah start to finish at least I was just
it was I was by myself my daughter came
in and wanted my she's five now I wanted
like play games and I thought to myself
you know what I'm gonna envelop this
young lady and just flat baskin the
father-daughter love kids I mean when
you have to put things in perspective
that's when you're losing by at least 25
want to win you don't I mean I want to
go through some sort of philosophical
gee you know mental jujitsu here
by the second quarter if you're going
like you know I got my health I got good
friends
you're losing really badly you're the
perfect person ask this bill burr why do
New England fans act so miserable why
must you be I know that we did oh stop
unhappy in order to be happy you don't
think so no I think that that's
everybody's reaction to the jealousy of
wanting to live through what we've lived
through in the last 15 years because
people always say stuff yeah they say
stuff like you know are you a [ __ ] you
one of those Tom Brady fanboys aren't
you like do I like the guy yeah of
course I do he's the greatest
quarterback of all time and then they'll
say stuff like but don't you get sick of
winning
don't you sick of it right isn't it like
boy everything must be like born cuz
that's all they have they all they have
no it's awesome I hope it continues and
I've enjoyed every second of it and when
it's over you know it's it's gonna be
over but like no matter what you know
happens like you're never gonna see
another run like this in a city that
only has four teams cuz you look at all
those cities like you know New York LA
Chicago where they have five on up just
they haven't even done it well I mean
this guy over there Brockman with his
Red Sox cap over there do you have a
David Price sound that where he was
bitching about David Price after the
Yankees beat him up in what was that
game - no I apologize - price on my
podcast I was like I was one of those
guy I mean I didn't just like yeah I
didn't believe in the guy same I thought
it was a head case and he wasn't he
turned I was complied never been happier
to be totally wrong but go for it for
Bill Berg I want him to quit I want him
to retire on the spot he's not gonna I
didn't go that's what I want and you
apologize that you'd be man enough to be
like yeah I got my butt kick again you
can't be on the Red Sox and just get
shelled repeatedly in Yankee Stadium not
think you're gonna get some flak over it
and then he redeemed himself in I loved
what he said he goes you guys had that
trump card in the after the game you
said that trump card for a long time you
don't have it anymore he's right that's
it but he couldn't have been like part
of you
so furious David Price severe but you
wish you were kind of feeling good
though like were you getting it off your
chest like you could what's therapeutic
saying
that's what what's with is there
something about another sports fan that
that sees their guy I don't know
just like I'm maybe I'm just a much more
sunny disposition type guy where you
screen this is about him this is about
how great he is okay I spent fed it to
me I want to tell you some rich all the
sports shows I go I I think you are the
nicest Pleasant respectful to other fan
base no I just think it goes back to
like the tea party you know it goes all
the way back to like like you don't feel
represented you feel like you're taxed
when I have another teammate come in to
studio because I'm teamed up against
two-on-one with the New York don't you
hate any time like there's a big Boston
game what they show they always show
like lighthouses lobster fishermen and
Paul Revere like I never saw any of that
growing up I didn't have any lobster
fisherman friends I never went to a
lighthouse and I never went to the
Freedom Trail I never did it I've seen
the line painted on the sidewalk you
know who goes to a tourist attraction in
your own city exactly then we do it when
relatives come to town what do you want
to go through the USS Constitution go to
a dive bar where do you want to go next
you want to go - Cheers
just to let you know it doesn't look
like that when you go inside so just
take a picture outside Ted Danson's not
there yeah you want to get some chowder
I hate clam chowder it's disgusting it
tastes like somebody already ate it and
then spit it back into the bowl looks
the same way it's going great man and
you know it just came out you know you
never know how you you know it seems
like it's going well you don't get
ratings with Netflix so you just go by
tweets and stuff so it seems like people
are enjoying it yeah we added Vince
Vaughn to the cast this year and yeah we
got we already had heavy hitters on Sam
Rockwell obviously lowered earn yeah
Justin Justin long David Koechner
mo Collins love Co Haley Reinhart I
gotta try to name everybody now it's
just just got nominated for an award
yeah it's awesome
did sit now that you have a child does
anything change with what you've done so
I go even harder I trash kids even even
more compensate one day your daughter's
gonna grow up and go what the hell was
dad doing what no I well I don't do like
jokes about my kid in my act cuz I
figured like you know I like bullies
already have enough material when you
show up with the wrong shirt they don't
need you know you don't need your dad on
TV telling stories about stuff that you
did so if she ever wants to get into the
public eye I'll let that be her decision
there you go
f is for family again third season of
this hilaryad animated Netflix series
about well I guess will you'd say it's a
dysfunctional family yes is it a
functional family based on your
experience is what you're saying would
you say well it's ramped up more than my
family but it's basically it's loosely
based on my family Mike prices everybody
in in there you know fans Peter
Billingsley everybody was just there
Mike leg nice all of these guys were
just there the in the beginning and we
were just sitting around talking about
what it was like growing up and you know
and in the 70s and what I love is the
look of the show was the 70s that I
remember where you know after the 70s
were over for some reason now it's
always lava lamps and AMC Pacers and I
remember when the AMC Pacer came out me
and my mother were laughing it that that
we like that is the ugliest car I've
ever seen in my life but now for some
reason whenever they do stuff on the
seventies they act like everybody
enjoyed that car and it was a big hit it
was like no it was bizarre I want to
play a new Rich Eisen show game with you
if you don't mind okay real bowl game or
not I figured you know what we want I
wanted to do this with these jamokes
over there this this week and I'm like
well I want to wait til bill burr came
in and I can play here we go real bowl
game or not I'm gonna favorite jamoke
everybody
true okay so these are names of real
bowl games or not you have to save
whether it's real or not like the
Hollywood Squares of bowl games gets
this play that's right doper first one a
bad boy mowers Gasparilla Bowl
true or false absolutely false bad boy
mowers a Gasper Oh bowl is true no it is
division 5 who's playing in that
Gasparilla bowl game Community College
mowers Gasparilla Bowl that how about
this next one for you farmersonly.com
agriculture bowl true or not true that's
false there is no such that amazing next
one up makers wanted Bahamas Bowl true
or false
no ice false is in fact true Florida
International against tomato on December
23 because there was booze involved some
of you like but isn't it promoting
alcoholism is it not it's an it is
actually a Thomas a Robinson National
Stadium in the Bahamas and Nassau but
let me get you a cat or dog drunk is
Marshall versus South Florida and
Raymond James Stadium and tamp on
December 20 okay next one quit smoking
Bowl presented by chantix this is so
hard because you've already had three
that sounded like BS this definitely
sounds like BS you're in my head right
now this is like rock paper scissors I'm
gonna say false it is false
no if your where'd that ray Liotta's
quit smoking have you seen that
commercial during it during your
football yeah yeah I know that he's
playing catch with the dog and then he's
studying scripts on the set yeah that's
it's it's working for me I did it with
that guy that guy's the awesome guy we
love we love what he comes on here okay
next one red box Bowl the red box Bowl
like right movies outside of the grocery
store red box red box Bowl I don't even
know what that is
it's the box it's outside of the it's
the groceries
you can get dollar movies out of the
river false oh that's true
it is it's Michigan State versus Oregon
okay last one for you see that
derogatory towards redheaded women
though I mean I think we have to like we
have to really sit there we've it's we
need to be better men last one for the
bill Pirate's Booty Bowl I hope it's it
is false
Victor in the game she's at ball is
California versus TCU she's at both
thanks for playing bill all right thank
you you were you were I think you were
too first six right there okay it's like
math class back in the day that's my
average last one for you are you
involved in better call soul if I was I
wouldn't be able to tell you that smart
aside I uh are you involved in the movie
that's coming no I'm out of the loop you
know what it is just because they go
back in time and I feel like the amount
of hair and makeup they'd have to do
considering I had hair when I was on
Breaking Bad I just think they don't
have it in the budget yet that's a green
screen a wig on do it Vince Gilligan
Vince is the best and I I was I actually
got to hang out with him also a
helicopter pilot and we got to hang out
and did he fly someone yeah yeah we've
around we had a great time Wow yeah he's
a badass he's a badass to bill burr
thanks for coming on happy holidays
Annika any time bro don't worry I'll
give you I'll give you full carte
blanche in your household to put blue
lights up anybody says to you how dare
you step on Hanukkah you sent him to me
okay I got your back okay I just wasn't
sure in this this current climate it's
fine
okay it's for family third season on
Netflix streaming now at Bilborough the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience